all right so we 10 we went for 180 or PI
radians every time right the first time
we did something a little bit different
what about just so much time to do so
okay now I picked the same name we can
just so we can get on with seeing what
kind of pattern do I have right and this
is the trickiest of a lot that's why I
left it to last so it's the same egg or
the same related angle okay
so PI on 6 is still going to be my first
solution okay so you can see in their
pulses now think normally you know we're
going from 0 to PI so what's your other
solution within that domain my radians
so it's going to be now look see you can
see again this symmetry coming into play
right here's PI radians PI love seeks I
went forward all right when I go from PI
I go backwards just that little bit you
can see how it's the same little that's
[ __ ] right so that's what gives me to
find PI on 6 there are my first two
solutions okay yeah okay
I'm gonna get two hopefully I'm gonna
answer it let me let me try and see
what's happening there as I keep going
right Oh is your PI plus my angle then I
went one PI minus my angle what happens
to my next pair of solutions well it's
two pi that's where my intercept is plus
that little angle right 2 pi plus PI on
6 so again that's going to be that team
6 right yeah so 2 pi forward now to get
my next solution I'm gonna go 3 PI and
backwards so 3 PI is 18 PI on 6 so if I
go back that's gonna be 17 PI on six hmm
now let me show you list out these
solutions and put it into a form which I
will show the pattern little more
clearly I've got this planet
right I've got zero lots of pie and then
I go forward pilot six there's solution
one now my next one I get one lot of pie
but then I have to go backwards right by
Plan C then my next time I'm shooting
lots and I have to go forward that got
me into 13 high and then I need three
lots and then I go back with okay now at
this point I think we're starting to see
pain but the tricky thing is well how do
you write it you could write as two
different parts you could say look all
the even ones right you go forward so
it's a bit like cosine with that - and
then all the odd ones you go backwards
okay now file that away for later we are
gonna do that later on it will actually
become usable but what we're trying to
get at this stage is just one line like
this that just nicely nicely sort of
says the whole cell so how do I get this
whole set sometimes it's got plus and
sometimes it's got - now I'm some of you
have met this before okay some of you
have seen this answer I'm trying to get
across to you why the answer is actually
a really ingenious way to go about it
rather than just some weird awkward
thing to remember okay as I go from one
to the next
okay I want to go plus minus plus minus
plus minus okay so I'm gonna introduce
something which changes sign every time
I go up by one okay it's cool
I just want right up next to it okay
it's called a switching factor okay so
here's the way it works if I want to
have a plus here I'm going to add on -1
^ whatever what of Pi I've gots on this
case at 0 ok now you're like huh what's
that mean we'll just stay with me okay
anything to the power of 0 it's just 1
right so this so far checks out it's
going to be naught PI plus 1 lot of -6
thumbs up now what happens when I take
this switching fact into the next line
I've got 1 lot of Pi so I'm gonna add on
one lot of this switching thing can you
see that
this one to the power it goes back and
forth as I go up each number okay so
what am I gonna get here one lot of
minus one which is what I wanted
what happens next layer to PI plus two
months of this with you you started to
see what's going on right because of
this double negative I go back to plus
right and this is true but yeah it is so
smart
except you know a lot of people the
first time they man it's just like he is
here's some forms go memorize them and
then go off and you know be fruitful
month way so my bad right and you have
no sense in this is actually the
ingenious way to succinctly Express
something that's really a mess right so
what's the what's the final solution at
the end I'm going to use this green way
of writing it okay and it's going to be
X is equal to now what is this at the
front I've got my my counter all right
so that's my m and what's pi then I add
this switching thing which sometimes
takes me forward sometimes takes me
backward whatever I need based on it
times my little related angle PI on six
right just like I have here and just
like a night an example was planned for
okay so in a nutshell those are the
general solutions now I promised I would
give you a nice neat table which shows
you how they all do that now they all
fit together and in general terms rather
than in these specific examples okay so
draw yourself up a two by three table
two columns and I better just draw it
for you because we'll get the wrong
numbers
two three and one okay so this table
will give you it's all of the formulas
this is a party people have to memorize
okay for all of this I'm gonna give it
to you in radians and I'm going to give
to you in degrees as well because
sometimes the question will be in
degrees works but you know so let's do
it for ten was first then we did cause
and then we decide which is kind of
funny usually do it in reverse order
I can you see now why I did tab first
cuz it's the easiest kind of general
solution but in radians first and then
we'll do degrees okay so what was it we
said that you get your little related
angle I'm gonna call that feet up you
know it's pine for here it's plant six
I'll use plant six again okay so I'm
going to say it's n PI plus feet up okay
we're theater is that first solution a
small decision acute solution that you
get so therefore if we convert it to
degrees what are you going to have
it'll be 180 m degrees plus theta
degrees that's not so hard right okay
move on to cosine had a cosine where
every even what on PI to PI 4 PI 6 by 8
pi you take that and then you backwards
and forwards okay so I'm gonna get to M
PI plus or minus whatever that related
angle is 0.64 compare that yes so if I'm
asked for the general solution you used
but this is the general that's the
general solution you're pretty much
these sort of catches it's a way of it's
a faster way of writing by on 611 pants
8:13 pants it's rather listing them all
out if I put in different values for
happen I'll get every single one out
okay so it's fun right here remember two
pi is actually 360 so this is 360
degrees plus or minus theta degrees plus
one for signed the weird but really
clever one okay we start with n PI then
we have to add this switching thing
which takes you backwards and forwards
right and then you multiply that by the
middle angle pilots it's in this case
how does it work over here it's just
going to be 180 okay now don't forget
for all of these because we've
introduced this amp right yeah you must
say what it is and later on you'll see
I'll give you reasons why sometimes you
introduce a second letter but you need
to actually say what they are and the
fact that they're integers is crucially
important okay